Estamos aquí
para anunciar el acuerdo del partido socialista
obrero español
y disper Cataluña
que hemos alcanzado 1 acuerdo para la investidura
de Pedro Sánchez
como Presidente del gobierno de España.
1 acuerdo que constituye 1 oportunidad histórica
para resolver 1 conflicto
que solo desde la política puede y debe resolverse.
Solo desde la negociación
deben resolverse los desencuentros.
1 acuerdo entre 2 formaciones
que tenemos discrepancias profundas
pero que somos capaces de lograr
puntos de encuentro
para el bienestar de los ciudadanos
y la solución de los problemas.
Es 1 acuerdo que llega en 1 momento clave para el país.
Es necesario formar cuanto antes
1 gobierno progresista que dé estabilidad a España
y que dé cumplimiento al mandato de la ciudadanía.
De las pasadas elecciones del 23 de Julio,
los españoles dijeron no a 1 gobierno del PP y Vox
y dijeron sí a 1 gobierno del PSOE.
Dijeron no al retroceso, dijeron no a la crispación,
al enfrentamiento, incluso al odio,
y dijeron sí al acuerdo, a la convivencia,
a la política de igualdad y al progreso.
Pues bien,
esta es la manera que tenemos nosotros de hacerlo,
con generosidad y altura de migas.
Han pasado 6 años desde 2017
y el conflicto de fondo en Cataluña
sigue sin resolverse.
Hemos dado pasos importantes estos años
y ahora, a pesar de las profundas divergencias,
estamos preparados para abrir 1 nueva etapa histórica,
1 etapa histórica en la que
a partir del respeto y el reconocimiento del otro
Se busque 1 situación política y negociada,
la oportunidad es real y la voluntad también.
Las urnas nos Han dado esa posibilidad y eso
es lo que vamos a hacer.
Nuestro objetivo es abrir Paso a 1 legislatura
que nos permita avanzar y construir 1 sociedad abierta
y moderna, 1 país mejor,
consolidar los logros conseguidos y no dejar
que el pasado condicione el futuro